predators are one thing but predatory
people other tribes man they're brutal
they're brutal what about your predatory
friend oh that's pretty bad too the
friend who stabs you in the back the
person who betrays you well how about
when you betray yourself
oh yeah what's the ultimate predator
what's the ultimate predator what's the
enemy you harbor in your own heart who
hates you that's the ultimate predator
dr jordan peterson welcome to the show
all right chris
good to see you how's the tour going
it's going great
it's um
the
crowds are
well dressed
extremely positive there for good
reasons
apolitical in in the most in the best
sense of the word
uh welcoming
the
theaters are packed
the lectures are going well to extremely
well the
time i spend afterwards meeting people
is it's like
being in a wedding celebration i would
say that's the closest thing i could
what do you mean
well you know you go to a wedding and
you meet all sorts of people you don't
know generally and everyone's happy to
be there and they're all looking good
because they dressed up for the occasion
and it's a positive event and
and
that's the closest analogy that i that
that i can
think of that would
describe what's happening
so
and uh
people that are there are there because
they're trying to put their lives
together and
they are putting them together and it's
working and
so
everything about it is as positive as it
can be fundamentally
so your hat's going great i saw you took
a trip to the tesla factory what were
your thoughts after meeting elon musk
did he get to speak too much uh i
wouldn't say much we we spoke probably
for 20 minutes in total
not purely privately because there's
other people around but
you know i just that just barely gets
you to know the surface of someone like
musk because he's an amazing person and
god only knows what's
what's up with him all things considered
we saw his new truck he was taking
people out for a ride i i didn't
i didn't go out for a ride
the truck's an amazing piece of
engineering the factory is massive um
you know what do you say about someone
who built a functional electric car then
shot it into space on a rocket
he's a singular person but i i thought
it went very well it was a very
interesting evening
so i was pleased to be there and
you know we sort of walked around each
other a bit and
it was just fine you guys interact a
fair bit on twitter
we seem to yeah yeah what do you think
that is why are you converging
i don't know i don't know exactly um
we're both well known and i suppose to
some degree that
that increases the probability of that
kind of convergence
but
maybe he's aiming up
me too
he seems to be he's aiming up literally
he's aiming up very literally yeah
definitely didn't he put a
wasn't there a spaceman a model of a
spaceman in the driver's seat of the car
that he put out into the schools that
that's certainly possible he's got a
theatrical uh twist there's no doubt
about that and a great sense of humor
because that's really funny to shoot
your own car out into space on a rocket
that's
a pretty damn good joke
what is it
what is it that's or why is it that
someone like elon has got himself to the
stage where he can say things that
almost every other see he's the richest
man i don't think he's got himself to
that stage i think he's always done that
and so now he still knows how to do it i
mean you know people think
i'll say what i have to say when i get
to the point where i'm protected and
secure it's like first of all
being protected and secure does not give
you the courage to say what you have to
say that's that's a completely
that theory couldn't be more backwards
you think you're going to get braver and
braver as you get more and more
protected you think that's how the world
works i mean i've watched university
professors think that at some point
they're going to say what they think as
they develop their career but by the
time they're protected and secure
they've spent so much time not saying
what they think that they aren't even
who they were and they don't know what
they think
so
no he says what he says because he's
always done that
and
people who are like him are like that
and so
steve jobs i presume was exactly the
same way i mean i know people who knew
him he always said what he thought and
and he was pretty damn cut and dried
about it which is why the apple products
are such miracles of of technological
mastery he had a unbelievably canny
design eye and was very
uh
he cut whole projects
without a second thought in some sense
when they weren't working he did that
when he came back to apple the second
time refined the entire product line got
rid of a ton of different things instead
of focusing on this yeah right right so
that was proof i mean maybe it was fluke
the first time which it wasn't but
coming back and doing it again the
second time showed pretty clearly it
wasn't same with same with elon right
he's refined down what he does to
a couple of very very tight parameters
now he seems to have although his hit
the enterprise he's put together is
unbelievably
high functioning i mean to produce a an
automobile sub industry that's actually
competitive and to
bring down the cost of space exploration
by a factor of 10 and to invent reusable
rockets and to have developed this
boring technology it's it's miraculous
he's probably an alien yeah probably
probably there's only two probably a
reptilian american car companies i think
that haven't gone bust
ford and tesla
and tesla came very close a number of
times
yeah it's an amazing accomplishment
so
go elon as far as i'm concerned yeah
he's a remarkable person
what color
skin emoji do you use
if i used one it would be black
why
why not
it's so preposterous all of that
you know everything that's happened to
rogan all this idiocy around race
this insistence that we can be reduced
to our
our race our ethnicity our sexual
identity
it's so appalling and
it's so uh
destructive in one of the reasons that i
had a lot of reasons for
making my political stance in
relationship to
canada's compelled speech laws
i had a lot of reasons for
making my views about that known
one of them was
the fact that my government had
introduced
a bill that required
me to say things a certain way
which was an unparalleled move in the
history of western democracies and
something the americans had made
strictly unconstitutional i believe in
1942
so that was part of it
part of it was i knew that this
top-down mandated
belief that
confusion around gender identity was
a positive
occurrence
to provide that freedom let's say i knew
that for every person that saved that
would doom a thousand people
primarily girls
to a kind of psychological contagion as
confusion about sex and gender identity
ramped up
i knew the literature on psychological
contagion uh it was it's what is that
psychological contagion
you could think about them as
psychological epidemics
so the last one the last one of any real
size was the
satanic daycare scares in the 1980s
but you're probably not old enough to
remember that but
the largest longest senses in u.s
criminal justice history were handed out
often to women who were accused of late
onset female sexual predation of
children in daycare centers
the fbi invented a whole new category of
perpetrator category that didn't exist
because there are no late onset female
sexual
child sexual predators
they don't exist
but there were women who
obtained prison sentences of several
hundred years for hypothetically being
involved in these satanic daycare
abuse rituals and there was a it just
swept across the whole country like the
salem witch trials except at a much
larger scale there's a book called
satan's silence that was written by a
lawyer and a social worker that
documents it it's just unbelievable
there were stories about
underground tunnels where children were
being taken down and being well every
possible thing you could think of was
happening to them all in the name of
like satanic
ritual
it was a contagion
and those things happened it happened
with cutting
behaviors it happened with uh eating
disorders this is almost all among girls
because their teenage girls are most
prone to this
they called it hysteria back in freud's
time but
there's a book by a man named henry
ellenberger called
discovery of the unconscious that traces
back psychogenic epidemics to about 300
years
and i knew that
you know people
in adolescence especially people of a
certain personality
configuration
um have some trouble settling into a
stable identity and
for a variety of reasons it can be high
negative emotion
which is associated with low self-esteem
those are more or less the same thing
and then in all likelihood high trait
openness which is the creativity
dimension and the high trade openness
people they're the ones that are more
likely to have green hair and red hair
and lots of piercings and lots of
tattoos and dress in a somewhat
in a non
standard manner let's say that's all
associated with creative behavior and
they have trouble catalyzing a single
identity
and then if you throw in categorical
confusion which is exactly what you're
doing when you declare that there's you
know an endless number of gender
identities then
people who are prone to identity
dissociation and to psychogenic
uh um
contagion
they're you're gonna
demolish them there isn't abigail
schreier has documented that quite
nicely in in her book
irreversible damage and
it's way more girls than boys and
it's thousands and thousands and
thousands of them so you think well
perhaps a few people who are
transgender benefited from this new
reality but for everyone who's benefited
and you know i'd like to see the data
just showing how much they actually
benefited
that'll take a long time to accrue
there's a thousand people who've been
just demolished by this
so and then
what else on the
well that that's basically that on the
political front i could see all that
coming i talked to the canadian senate
about it when they put in the
legislation they didn't listen they just
thought racism bigotry sexism it's like
yeah
have it your way
but you know so what all these girls
that have
rapid onset gender dysphoria and
disfiguring themselves and taking
hormones and
you know wreaking havoc with themselves
and their families and the broader
culture
these people that were so woke and so
permissive you think they're gonna have
that on their conscience
they're on to something
some other noble venture
so
give me your thoughts on the modern
dating market
well i'm too old to really have any
thoughts on it in some sense not from a
personal perspective
well
i don't understand that level of detail
you know
i i do know some things that are
happening perhaps at universities where
there are far more girls than boys or
women than men
what happens in those institutions
this is what it looks like anyways
possibly
so females are hypergamous which means
they'll mate across and up
hierarchies
uh socioeconomic hierarchy but
competence hierarchy is really at the
bottom of it
and so when you set up a situation where
there's far more
women than there are men in a given
domain say where mate selection can take
place
most of the men still don't do very well
because most of them are still rejected
by women
but a small minority of men do
extraordinarily well if you think well
means unlimited sexual access and so
what's happening in the universities is
that
a small minority of men
have sexual cart blush in some sense
and
most men are in the same position that
most young men are always in which is
they're in a state where they're not
particularly desirable to women and then
the women of course are terribly
frustrated because the minority of men
that they would really like to have
long-term relationships with
it's it's a
it's a
seller's market for those they're not
settling down that's the sex ratio
hypothesis yeah and the reverse happens
right that you see whoever the more
scarce sex is gets to determine the
rules of the game
so the men
if they are in high demand because the
short supply
you get uh more short-term mating yeah
you get um
an
increase in relationship dissatisfaction
from women and when the reverse happens
you get
more dates before
sex you get more long-term mating
you also get more sexual violence in
that situation as well when there is a
surplus of men and a scarcity of women i
think this is
far more unstable societies
you know i was pilloried a few years
back from my comments about enforced
monogamy because they were taken out of
context and twisted
in exactly the way that things like that
get twisted now but
what did you mean by that
i mean that
one of the
one human universal is the construction
of societies to both mandate and reward
monogamy and there's all sorts of
reasons for that it's because it's the
best long-term solution fundamentally
but one of the reasons for that is that
when women are scarce men get violent
now you know that was read to say well i
thought that this society should be
distributing women to undeserving men
which is of course absolutely utterly
preposterous and
bears no relationship whatsoever to
anything i ever said or thought or
anything anyone saying would ever think
or say or has ever thought or said
because i don't know anyone politically
ever who was insane enough to think that
this state should distribute women to
men like that's just never happened so
to be accused of that belief and then
for that to
you know be put forward as a credible
representation of what i thought was
just one of the preposterous things that
has happened to me it's an unfortunate
name enforced monogamy because it's a
term from anthropology right but it what
you mean is
culturally celebrated monogamy
culturally and norms that are supporting
people and raising that opportunity
and supporting and punishing both but
mostly supporting i mean the punishing
is that
there's there's a moral
uh disapproval
applied to say cheating
right to adultery
to especially running around behind your
partner's back if you're married
particularly that but even if you're
even if you're in a long-term stable
relationship it's like well that's all
enforcement it's not police with jack
boots but
that's not the only type of enforcement
it's not the only type of sanction or
threat or punishment or disappropriation
or disgust or contempt or shame or
frustration or disappointment all of
those things
and
all of that because monogamy
is a good long-term solution but
in some sense a troublesome short-term
solution
if you have other options
then all of those
elements of social support let's say
need to be put into place
and that is it as far as i've been able
to determine by looking at the
anthropological literature
norms surrounding monogamy are a human
universal there are exceptions but
they're very there are very specific
situational reasons for those exceptions
so you see the ons data that came out a
couple of weeks ago that said for the
first time ever since records began
50.1 percent of women are childless by
30. so there are more women without
children at 30 than there are women with
children the first time well so this is
somebody clipped
a part of
one of my podcasts i believe it was
where i was talking about
what what our society does to 19 year
old women or 18 year old women 19 year
old women we just lie to them all the
time you know the first lie is
there's nothing more important than your
career more or less by definition so
that's the first lie the second lie is
there will be nothing more important to
you
in your life than your career
so that's the second lie and then the
third lie is there should be nothing
more important in your life than their
career so that's the third lie
and then
the implicit in that is the idea that
children are a burden and that the idea
that women
should have children
is part of the oppressive patriarchy and
should be resisted and who are men to
tell me what i can do with my body and
hey fair enough and etc etc
now
i've worked in female dominated
occupations my entire life i worked for
example i worked
as a daycare uh
worker
way back when that was like 19 probably
80 something like that and there were no
men doing that but i really liked kids
and so that was fun and i worked for
social services in alberta in the in the
child care department and uh then i've
been working as a psychologist
either training or as a psychologist
since then and that's been a female
dominated enterprise increasingly as the
years went by but even when i
was first
when i first entered it
so i
i'm in the post
female in the workplace generation
firmly
i never experienced the world
except as that and so i've watched women
progress through their professional
careers at every level of attainment
from the lowest to the highest
and observed what happened and
relatively
i would say bias free because i didn't
know
and
what i've seen is that as women progress
towards their
late thirties
no late
twenties they
there's a psychological transformation
and what happens is that they place less
emphasis on their career and
way more emphasis particularly on having
a child
and that really reaches a crisis point
around 29 or 30 for the vast majority of
women and and their attitude flips and
i've seen it flip very dramatically with
many women
and i suppose the most
signal
single
most
uh
convincing
evidence of that i worked with
high-end lawyers in toronto for about 10
years
i was part of an organization we went to
law firms
high-end law firms and said
send us your most productive people
and we'll help them iron out whatever
wrinkles there might still be in their
life and the advantage to them is that
things will go better for them and the
advantage to you is they'll be even more
productive
and there's a good management dictum
which is pay the most attention to your
most productive people because they're
bringing in the bulk of your revenue
disproportionately and so i worked with
men and women who were at the peak of
their careers in a very difficult
enterprise
and so these were women who were
generally very attractive um well put
together physically
pretty stable psychologically
extremely conscientious very very smart
and high achieving from like junior high
all the way through
high school university
law school
onto
the top firms
rocketing up through the ranks full
partnership by the time they were 29 or
30 and all the law firms all the women
bailed out all of them the law firms
couldn't keep them
and i i was really and i talked to the
women a lot about a lot about this
because i was very interested in it
because i knew the law firms were
bending themselves over backwards and
tying themselves into knots trying to
retain these women because why wouldn't
they you know just just being greedy
capitalists is enough you know we don't
want to lose their high performing women
because they're performing at the
highest level and
they couldn't keep them the women wanted
to have nine to five jobs they wanted to
bind the job so they could have a life
and that was especially true once they
got interested in having a child or had
one and what what they really came to
was a very
uh interesting realization so
because they were highly conscientious
women they sort of did their duty and
and worked hard and diligently and
didn't pop their head up to ask
questions they're in junior high they
got the best grades they were in high
school they got the best grades and so
on all the way through
right till they reached partnership but
that's sort of an apogee right you hit
partnership in a senior law firm it's
like you're at you're at the top of your
profession
well then what
well so then they looked around and they
thought
here i am with all these like
hyper competitive men
perfectly willing to work 80 hours a
week non-stop to stay at the top
what the hell are they doing because
that's the real question
what is it
what is it that characterizes this small
percentage of hyper-competitive men it's
not
you can assume that that's how everyone
should be but first of all that isn't
how everyone is or you can flip that and
say well there's only a small minority
of human beings that are willing to do
this to work flat out eight hours a week
i mean they're getting they're certainly
being paid for it let's make no mistake
about that but
what about the rest of life
well that's what the women asked
why am i doing this
and that's a great question well for men
there's a different answer than for
women it's a really different answer and
it isn't like the men are exactly
thinking this through it's it's more
like this is an integral part of male
motivation
the more successful you are as a man the
more women like you but the problem that
you have now is that
as women are getting
better educated with more employment
more stateless more prestige they
compete themselves out of their ability
to find an attractive mate
as women raise up through the dominance
hierarchy and this is competence
competence hierarchy sorry
who's going to tell women
the
equal access to opportunity that you
have recently just acquired
actually what that's doing is it's
making it more difficult for you to find
a mate that you're fundamentally
attracted to yeah well it it it does a
lot of things i mean it does provide
women with a lot more uh opportunity on
the economic front it does
decrease their dependency on their mate
in relationship to economic security and
educating educating women
countries that are willing to educate
women that's the best predictor of their
future economic success so if you look
at developing countries and you want to
find out what about a developing country
is most likely to predict the fact that
they will continue to thrive
economically it's their attitude towards
the education of women and but a couple
more things
women's educational status predicts
their children's educational status but
men's educational status doesn't so
that's also an important
multi-generational effect
i i released a video i was going to
conclude that other story i released a
video
or someone released a clip of me talking
about some of the things we just talked
about
and it went out on youtube shorts and
it's got like five million views in a
month or something like that and the
comment section is unbelievably
vitriolic it's every single comment is
vitriolic and it's all from women it's
like who is this old white bastard
telling us what we should do with our
bodies you know when i wasn't being
judgmental i was just saying exactly
what i said to you which is well i've
watched women
over the entire course of my life with i
would say an affectionate eye you know i
love my sister i love my wife i have a
daughter i love my mother i'm pretty
happy about women all things considered
i don't have an axe to grind in
relationship to how they should conduct
their lives i don't even know how they
should conduct their lives i've watched
what happens and i've also watched what
happens to women who hit 29 or 30 and
then can't conceive
and that is not a fate i would wish on
anyone it's awful and 30 of couples fall
into that 30 of couples have difficulty
conceiving it's a lot and the
probability that you'll have difficulty
conceiving increases with age and so
you know
c'est la vie
and but it's very interesting to me to
see
how vitriolic those comments have been
and how how uniform that is because
usually on my youtube channel in
particular
95 of the comments are positive and this
is completely the opposite of that
so and then so you brought this up at
the beginning you said fifty percent of
women now at thirty point fifty point
one the childless by thirty yeah yeah
well you know
that's uh
that's not good that's a sign of
something profoundly wrong with the
entire culture at an extremely deep
level i don't think that
women need to take it as us trying to
tell women what they should or shouldn't
do but i think that it would be very
fair to say that you need to be an
incredibly unique woman to make it to 50
without a family and look back and think
yeah i did this right that's not to say
that those women aren't out there they
absolutely are i know some of them
but i think overall that it's well it's
the same with everyone for everyone i
mean
this is another example of how our
culture has just lost its moorings it's
like well what's life
well
you have a job or a career and hopefully
you're productive and you contribute
something to the community and you
provide yourself and your family with
the necessities of life that's a quarter
of your life or a third of it something
like that
you have an intimate relationship you
have a family
that's life
and if you don't have one of those
that's one-third of your life you don't
have now some people maybe they're doing
so well on the other two fronts
that they can cope with not having that
or maybe they're doing so well on one
front they can cope with not having two
of them compensates yeah maybe
it's pretty hard because if you want to
have a great career
it's hard to do that if you're alone in
without a family
right i mean the the people that i've
seen who've been best situated in their
life all things considered
even in relationship to their career
have a pretty solid monogamous
relationship that stabilizes them and
then they have a family that also
stabilizes them and broadens out their
life
and
you know exceptional people do
exceptional things and good for them but
they're
by definition given that they're
exceptional they're a tiny minority this
is always the argument between
conservatives and liberals right because
the liberal types they're more tilted
sometimes towards
what would you call it uh
compassion or appreciation for the
exceptional and fair enough the
exceptional is necessary but
on average
what everyone does on average is the
thing to do and so you just look you see
well what do people do well if they have
a job or career
they have an intimate relationship
and they have a family and if you don't
have
any one of those things well then you're
treading water harder doesn't mean you
can't do it and it doesn't even mean
possibly that you shouldn't try but
as a default
presumption it's just utterly
foolish
what else are you going to do with your
life well maybe you're wildly creative
fair enough you know
that's extraordinarily rare as well
subject to the power law problem in any
case which is even if you're hyper
creative the probability that you're
going to be successful at that
economically is extremely
extremely tiny to the point where it's
almost non-existent it's so difficult
now it does happen and some and you can
have spectacular success if you become
successful but wasn't it did you say
last night
of the 100 000 most recently printed
books only a thousand have sold more
than a million yeah something like that
it's something powerless all the way
down
everywhere everywhere power law that's
you know a tiny minority of people do
all the work a tiny minority of people
get all the benefit a tiny minority of
athletes score all the goals a tiny
minority of men get all the women etc a
tiny minority of stars have all the mass
a tiny minority of rivers have all the
water a tiny minority of cities have all
the people etc etc etc everywhere always
you know and and we're so clueless in
our culture that we blame that on
capitalism it's like
how does that account for the mass of
stars people
so or the you know the volume of rivers
or the population density of cities or
rolling the clock forward you and elon
tweeted recently about population
collapse what do you think is going to
happen there
oh well i've thought for at least 10
years that the biggest problem in 50
years will be that there's just not
enough people i remember hearing you say
a few years ago that you thought we'd
peak at about nine billion yeah we
probably won't hit nine yeah and i think
about stats because think about how
crazy it is to think that we might be
living on earth right now
at a time with the most number of humans
that are ever going to exist at one time
ever yeah that's highly probable and you
know in the past
the population collapse
in developed countries is precipitous
right it's like it fall we fall off a
cliff because it's the same everyone
knows this from the pandemic the arnold
number if fewer people are reproducing
next generation you have fewer people to
reproduce as fewer people are
reproducing and it
yeah yeah yeah yeah well i i worked on
un committee
it's got to be 10 years ago now
to help
draft the un secretary's general's
report on sustainable economic
development and so i looked at all sorts
of things like that i was very curious
for example about
because people have been beating the
overpopulation drum since
well
it really kicked in in the 1960s you
know because there were dire predictions
by the year 2000 the club of rome came
out and said well there'll be riots and
mass starvation and mass movement of of
migrants and all the things you hear
about climate change because there's too
many people on the planet and that just
didn't happen at all that was just that
it wasn't just wrong it was anti-true it
was absolutely wrong what happened
instead was that everyone got way richer
and
the bottom
section of the population in terms of
economic distribution got lifted out of
poverty inequality still exists but
that's that power law phenomena we
already talked about not that that's
trivial it's just unbelievably difficult
to determine what to do with there are
solutions but
certainly getting rid of capitalism
isn't the solution
and so
i looked at population trends and first
of all found
not that this is an act of genius or
anything that as soon as you educate
women
and
the the size of family shrinks
precipitously like below replacement and
that's partly because women have other
options that that's a huge thing is play
oh yes i mean all the all the countries
in the west are way below replacement
korea's way below replacement south
korea japan way below replacement
yeah yeah i think the number one good uh
number one on the planet it might be
chad
chad
the country in terms of growth uh eight
children on average yeah i think nigeria
will have more people in it than china
by the end of the century
so
yeah yeah yeah and musk you know he's a
far
looking man and
and so he's looking
around the apocalyptic corner let's say
like oh we're running out of people and
what that means of course is that you
run out of young people
right you don't run out of old people
first because everyone
who is here now is going to be 30 years
older in 30 years and
it'll be young people we don't have
enough of and of course young people are
the ones who do the innovation and are
going to do most of the heavy lifting
etc and so there's going to be a
terrible shortage of young people well
you see this with some of the things
that i i posted that ons data the 50.1
percent of women childless by 30 and
both men and women are replying to that
tweet saying well good there's too many
people on the planet in any case i'm
thinking how
this
npc midwitary is so dangerous because it
makes people believe that they actually
have
something grounded backing up their
claims yeah yeah well and that this idea
that the planet has too many people on
it this is
there's no
sentiment more implicitly genocidal than
that statement
[Laughter]
so what do you mean too many people
exactly and what do you mean the planet
and what do you propose to do about that
exactly mass abortion is that your
answer or should we do something a
little more dramatic maybe we'll just
shame people out of having children and
i've seen people do that literally i saw
a professor when i was at an um
[Music]
a ted i think it was it
doesn't matter it was a number of
professors talking to a couple hundred
students and one of the professors who
was an environmentalist activist type
and he got up on stage and shook his
finger to the whole young crowd saying
that him and his wife had only decided
to have one child which was in my
opinion one child too many for him and
told all the young people there if they
had a shred of ethical decency that they
would lim severely limit their
reproductive potential and
i stood up and said that i thought that
was the most one of the most appalling
things i'd ever heard anyone in academia
say to young people which is really
saying something because they say plenty
of appalling things and it was a very
uncomfortable moment and he huffed off
the stage but
you know in a frenzy talking about how
you couldn't talk about such things
without being pilloried on ethical
grounds and yeah that's for sure you
come out
as a what emissary of the academic
establishment you tell young people that
humanity is so corrupt that they should
seriously consider not propagating
because that violates the deepest of
ethical norms and you think that's a
good thing and that that's your right
and
it was just
beyond comprehension it's beyond
comprehension but it's associated with
like a deeply rooted
existential self-hatred
and i mean hatred at the level of
humanity is like a virus on the planet
that we're a cancerous group alex
epstein calls this human racism
right
right right it's that yeah well we're a
cancer on the planet you know unchecked
growth just like a cancer
it's like that's us a cancer it's okay
we know where your heart is
located
because what's what's the implications
for for a doctrine like that what do you
do with the cancer
cut it out yeah that's for sure poison
it or whatever whatever there's nothing
you don't do to a cancer
so you're gonna use a metaphor like that
there's too many people on the planet
you're gonna use a metaphor like that
you know and then you're gonna you're
gonna also decide that you're virtuous
while you're using it because you're on
the side of the planet whatever the hell
that means
so yeah it's it's unbelievable and a
huge part of it's rooted in this
existential
shame and
and and horror at the condition of being
human and the fact that life is rife
with suffering and a lot of it's
unjustified and
you know it's a mephistophelian position
so mephistopheles was
laid out portrayed in kurthus faust
that's
the story of a man who sold his soul to
the devil for knowledge it's a story of
intellectual pride and
gurtha stands in relationship to german
literature in the same manner that
shakespeare stands in relationship to
english literature and girth is
mephistopheles
says straight out twice in in the play
once in the first
his two books and once in the first book
and once in a second gareth has restated
twice
existence is such a foul thing because
of all its suffering essentially that it
would be better if it was merely enough
annihilated
and that's the mephistophelian stance
this whole show should just come to a
halt look at how corrupt people are evil
reigns everywhere it's nothing but will
to power we're destroying the planet
um with our unchecked ambition all of it
rooted in greed and and and
machiavellianism and jockeying for
position and we're so contemptible that
we should just roll up and die
and we should shame women into not
having children and we should shame men
so they never manifest any planet
destroying ambition and
it's
it's unbelievably appalling it goes all
the way down to the bottom
the bottom of things that's what's
tearing our culture apart this dispute
about
the nature of existence at the most
fundamental level
so and the universities have come out on
the wrong side
so
talking about the individual one of the
things that i see holding people back is
comfort so it's easy to get life to a
stage where it's not that bad
it's not that good
either at least when you have a full-on
breakdown there's only one way to go
right you're only going to go up from
there but i think it's possible to
wallow for years in a just about
passable life right sedated by comfort
and i see this temptation in myself as
well to give up the good for the great
what would you say to people who are
trying to escape this curse of
mediocrity
well if you're satisfied with it in some
fundamental sense i mean there's there's
something to be said i suppose for
walling off a private space for yourself
if you can maintain it and
detaching yourself to some degree from
the troubles of the world and
maintaining your own little private
garden
the problem with that is the snakes tend
to seep in from the outside right it's
it's pretty difficult to wall yourself
off in any real sense from the concerns
of the world
so it isn't clear to me that that's a
viable solution
it also means that you might justify to
yourself lack of civic engagement you
know i shouldn't go to church i
shouldn't take part in the political
process because it's also corrupt i
should hide myself from
all the annoying
noise that's generated constantly on the
media front i have some sympathy for
that viewpoint but
i don't believe it's really possible
because
you can't have
you can't have a walled garden
independent of independently of the
health of the broader society it's just
not possible maybe you can have it for a
very short period of time but
so
but if you're if you're comfortable with
what you have and it's gin it's genuine
comfort then i think hey but generally
it's not i think for the most part it's
it's people that have become sedated you
know they've forgotten their dreams but
they've forgotten that they've forgotten
them pink floyd's comfortably numb is
about this right they've become
comfortably numb
i think most people i had i have this
friend and this this story really hit me
so um during the pandemic
running a podcast i was able to have the
thing that i feel i'm good at my
artistic pursuit and outlet that was
available for me to continue it was
actually increased because i didn't have
other stuff to do
i have a friend that's a barber and he
got a job at a supermarket barbara's
shut down for a long period of time he
got a job at a supermarket stacking
shelves overnight and i asked him i was
like man how are you how are you finding
the new job this is a big a big change
he's like do you know what it is i
actually don't mind the work i mean the
people that i work with
but man i miss being good at something
right right right well dude that hit me
yeah so hard right i missed being good
at something yeah yeah well people need
the opportunity
to be good at something it so then you
might ask yourself well what's the best
antidote to the discomfort of life and
you might say
well it's comfort
and
i suppose that's what you
act out when you swaddle a baby
but
a better antidote is something like
adventure to excellence
and
that's far better antidote to suffering
than the mere absence of suffering
so
not to say that the mere absence of
suffering that's not nothing you know
stepping out of that
sedation from comforts difficult though
especially if you've become routine eyes
to it yeah well that's the difficult
difficulty of maturity you know the
freudians said very wisely that the good
mother necessarily fails
it means she stops providing the comfort
that insulates people against the need
for adventure i heard you say recently
that um
a mother's ability to let her child go
out into the world knowing that they're
still vulnerable and that it's now down
to them and the world to look after them
that's one of the bravest things it's
the female crucifixion
so and that's exemplified best in well
the best
portrayal of that i've seen is
michelangelo's pieda
now it's it's a statue of mary
and she has christ's body on her as an
adult on her lap and she's broken and
destroyed and you know she's displaying
that
and that's
that's the bravery of a mother to
allow that to happen but not only that
to to facilitate it
facilitate it so what about where you go
kid where you go where you go
well why it's dangerous out there it's
like yeah no kidding
it's more dangerous here if you stay
with me
by a lot
so you might lose your body out there in
the world but if you stay here you lose
your soul
how do you see that as an individual
let's say that there isn't the mother
there that's pushing you along
well you know one of the things jung
carl jung
was very interested in the eatable
complex and that's basically that
overprotective maternal
and he
he criticized freud
for presuming that it was
really something the mother did
he says it's more relational than that
first of all it would be something the
father would allow to happen assuming
there was a father around so let's not
forget about the paternal contribution
to allowing that to occur
because in some sense it's the father's
role to
serve as the antithesis of that maternal
overprotection so a woman is extremely
bonded with her infant say between zero
and nine months and the infant is
utterly helpless
and so
complete compassion and the provision of
comfort is the only job that matters and
that's really the case
and then the woman has to switch gears
to some degree the mother has to switch
gears as the child starts to become
more
more mobile fundamentally and more
independent she has to let go of the
infant which is a real grieving process
and
she has to start to facilitate this
movement towards independence but that's
a hard shift and so partly the role of
the father
in that is to be an advocate for the
child's independence and to
comfort the mother to let her know that
that degree of security provision is no
longer necessary but also to
act as an advocate for the child's
outgoing uh
outgoing desire
and so so it's the edible situation is
not only the mother it's also say the
weak father but then it's also the child
so you can imagine because you young
belief that these
negotiated agreements were
were relational
so you know you're
six
you're in grade one
maybe you're feeling a little ill
maybe you're not maybe you're playing
with being a little ill and maybe you're
playing with exaggerating how ill you
are and your mom comes downstairs and
says
you know you've got a test today at
school maybe you haven't quite prepared
for it maybe you know you should have
and she says but you know you you seem
to have a tummy ache
maybe you're too sick to go to school
and the kid thinks
maybe i could just stay home and
you know mom could tuck me in and i
wouldn't have to take that test and
i wouldn't have to confront the world
and he says yeah
yeah my stomach really hurts and
and away we go
and the child has made a choice
and you think well that's and that's a
catastrophic choice and you think well
children shouldn't be held accountable
for choices they make at that age it's
like
that child's soon going to be an adult
that's going to make very similar
decisions
the
the choice has consequences and to be
held accountable for that is to
recognize purely that the choice has
consequences and that it is a choice now
you know you could say well 95 of the
blame is to be put on the mother and
maybe that's an overestimate i think it
probably is
but
the child could say mom you don't have
to worry about me i'm gonna get up and
go do this
and
that's choice
and that's the right choice
so these are always chicken and egg
problems obviously but
that that fleshes out the complexity of
the situation you know if you're if
you're being enticed down a pathological
road
you can accept or reject the invitation
now some people are better at enticing
and some people enforce it more harshly
and you know there's all sorts of
individual variability in situations
like this but
just because you're offered debate
doesn't necessarily mean that you have
to take it
so and i'm not a determinist i do
believe that people have free will
whatever that means
that's a murky subject and it gets
complicated the more you look at it but
whatever it's still a good shorthand way
of describing the fact that we seem to
be
cursed with responsibility for our own
destiny at least to some degree
how do you advise people that are
dealing with imposter syndrome oh
everyone deals with that
every time you make a status shift as
you move upwards of course you have
impostor syndrome because when you first
make a transition into a new role you
are an imposter because you're a
beginner you don't know what you're
doing and that doesn't mean you're a
liar or a fake and it doesn't mean you
should presume more knowledge than you
have
it's what did nietzsche say every great
man is an actor of his own ideal
and that's that's that's that feeds into
the imposter syndrome in some sense if
you want to move to the next stage at
some point you have to act like you're
already there when you're just barely
started
and that's not a lie
you know it's it's the willingness it
can be and it can degenerate into a lie
especially if you presume more than you
know
but
if you move you know let's say you move
from being an undergraduate to a
graduate student
well every all the other graduate
students and the professors know that
you're just a beginning graduate student
they're they're not going to expect as
much from you as they would from a more
seasoned graduate student
so you have some leeway that's genuine
but you are you know the low rung
occupier of that role and of course
you're going to feel like you're an
imposter
if you have any sense because you're
just barely there you just made the
transition that's okay you know that's
not a problem
first of all you have to understand that
everyone with any sense who isn't
narcissistic feels that and it's
actually an indication of your mental
health and your competence as long as
that doesn't become crippling it
shouldn't knock you out i'm such a phony
well don't be a phony that's the first
thing
if you're dealing with competent people
and you admit your ignorance the
competent people never judge you harshly
for that as long as you've been paying
attention
so in my classes for example people were
often afraid to ask questions and so
sometimes i would point to people and
ask them if they had a question
especially the quieter types
and they'd be afraid to ask the question
because while they're revealing their
ignorance and they would assume they're
the only person in the room that's that
ignorant but they're not because if they
were paying attention and they had a
question the probability that half the
class had that question was really high
that's different if you're not paying
attention and so you can be
ignorant you can be an ignorant newbie
and you can even ask the questions that
are necessary to ask in that position
and sort of reveal your inadequacy and
as long as you're dealing with competent
people
and you've been paying attention they're
they're just gonna answer your questions
then you only have to be ignorant once
that's the thing about asking
a stupid question
you only have to ask it once then you're
no longer stupid to well balanced people
that intellectual humbleness is
endearing right really endearing yes so
one of the things that i i want just
because they're always asking questions
too they always have imposter syndrome
too
if they have any sense like
what do you what are you more what you
know or what you don't know
well if you're competent you know you're
more what you don't know and so you're
always asking questions you see someone
else asking questions you think oh
you're asking questions you probably are
competent
so
and there's the trajectory that's the
trajectory of a person that will become
competent or more comfortable in the
future too right so that
what i would hope with imposter syndrome
and this is something that i noticed
first off in myself but then in other
people as well
um
i've bro scienced my way into something
called imposter adaptation
so hedonic adaptation is the
phenomenon where your happiness level
tends to reset after a change in
circumstances so you buy a new car or
get a new house or get the job promotion
and it feels good for a while but then
it resets imposter syndrome being that
you never feel fully worthy of any
achievements that you get in your life
and you don't feel like you are worthy
of being there imposter adaptation is a
real nefarious version of this where no
matter how many times you disprove your
lack of self belief it continues to
persist in the real world and this there
is a kernel of truth in this because
what you said if you're trailblazing if
you haven't done this thing before
but you also have to think well how many
times have i done something analogous to
this how many times have i done
something that's kind of like this but
not not quite yet well people who are
high in trait neuroticism are more
likely to feel that way because
so
neuroticism is the negative emotion
personality trait and it's a index of
sensitivity to
threat and punishment essentially
so imagine that it's very difficult to
calibrate how many units of
physiological preparedness you should
manifest per unit of threat
right because how big's the threat the
answer is
you don't know
you wake up in the morning and
you have an ache in your side
is that nothing
or is that the cancer that's gonna kill
you in six months and it's pretty low
probability that it's the latter but the
probability is not zero so why shouldn't
you be panicked out of your mind and the
answer is some people are
and sometimes they're right
so the calibration of threat especially
when it's associated with novelty is
virtu
an impossibly difficult computational
problem we have like 10 different
mechanisms to try to solve that and one
of the mechanisms is well there's
tremendous variability in response and
if you're higher in trait neuroticism
you're going to have the problem you're
described all the time you're going to
be doubtful about your
competence and the validity of your
position
and
the only treatment we really know for
that is to expose yourself to things
that you're afraid of voluntarily and to
become braver as a consequence of doing
that but some people have to live with
that more than other people
the thing that i realized was that
after a while if you continue to
disprove your imposter syndrome in the
real world yeah you have a challenge
you're adamant that you probably won't
or might not or don't deserve to get
past it and then you do
after a while you have to admit to
yourself that your imposter syndrome has
nothing to do with your capacity and
everything to do with your addiction
about feeling like an imposter yeah
and well and that that does change as
people age
generally speaking they become
more agreeable more conscientious and
lower in negative emotion
and some of that is that adaptation you
see that you've
survived through various challenges
and then you can review that evidence to
yourself but also the people around you
bolster you
because they have confidence in you and
so their anxiety doesn't trigger your
anxiety and they'll remind you too
you know you've got this you've done
things in this such a wealth of data you
know you've done it so many times yeah
and yeah i think and that and that does
help i mean it does help people get more
confident as they get older and they
accrue experience because of that but
it's subject to that
underlying
trait variability and sensitivity to
negative emotion i mean there there's
been good psychometric analysis of
self-esteem scales and
neuroticism scales
and they're that pretty much the same
thing
reversed
and so
are you confident in yourself
self-esteem
do you lack confidence trait neuroticism
and so it is harder for some people
because it takes more evidence for them
to dampen down their their response to
threat
so and and it's partly because
we're all adapted to some degree to the
failure of induction right just because
something happened multiple times in the
past does not mean
necessary that it will happen the next
time and that's a big bro it's the
farmer and chicken problem right
farmer's always feeding the chicken
chicken thinks the farmer's his best
friend but one day the chicken is dinner
and that's induction
there was a stable pattern in the past
you come to rely on it but at any time
that axiom can be disproved
and so
the fact that we have variability and
trait neuroticism is a consequence of
the the the probability of the failure
of induction
it's it's a very difficult problem to
solve how to regulate negative emotion
you know
and uh but i would say that
the best way we know is to keep
facing challenges voluntarily pay
attention
at a rate that works for you
develop your competence that actually
stabilizes the environment around you so
it's a it actually is less predictable
and less threatening plus you accrue
that evidence and you get the social
support for doing so that's your best
pathway forward
you said that a harmless man is not a
good man a good man is a very dangerous
man who has that under voluntary control
how should people become more dangerous
oh
becoming more articulate is definitely i
would say
that's the
primary array of weapons
so i mean physical prowess is something
and it's not nothing that physical
confidence that comes along with that as
well
but
the same thing replicated at the level
of the ability to communicate and to
think
that's a
way broader field of of
battle and opportunity
so
this is one thing that isn't taught well
especially to boys
it's more important to teach it to boys
i would say because they're more
skeptical of such of the educational
enterprise in general generally speaking
partly because they're less obedient
partly because they're less agreeable
that's particularly true for
disagreeable boys
and agreeable boys get higher grades
independent of their iq and their and
their academic achievement because
they're easier to deal with
so
what do you tell disagreeable boys
there's nothing that makes you more
formidable than verbal competence than
being able to articulate be able to
think to marshall your arguments right
some
battlefield metaphor
to get everything in order
get all your information straight
no to marshall your forces
and so i mean that's part of the reason
that rap
artists are so popular especially among
disaffected young men black and white
alike
because they're unbelievably articulate
they have this incredible verbal prowess
it's unbelievably attractive you know
and it's associated with genuine
artistic
and redemptive
activity
often focusing on
something that's approximately the voice
of the
underclass let's say
but a powerful voice right and
it's interesting to see how many young
white guys identify with that
was it alder suxley that wrote doors of
perception yeah yeah so this is kind of
an equivalent of that right that you
have a experience which many people
struggle to articulate you take the best
of us the one that has the most precise
most articulate erudite language
you drop them in and you say okay
show us what you've learned
this is the equivalent but for just a
different community a different sort of
life that maybe you don't have the
ability to describe what it feels like
to live
on a council estate in manchester or in
you know the one of the
neighborhoods of brooklyn or whatever it
might be
and then this person can
and it feels like it's your voice yeah
well you still if you're a young man you
still feel alienated from your place as
rightful heir of the proper kingdom i
mean that's an existential truism for
everyone for every particularly for
every young man because he is an
outsider in many ways he's young and
juvenile and not very highly valued and
and then
is is in some sense hurt by the
inadequacies of the current king the
current culture and and is easily turned
against it because of that and
that's the machinations of the evil
uncle that's the king arthur's story
that's the story of horus
horus and osiris it's an ancient ancient
story
it's the story of sauron and
it's there all the time and you see in
that in rap music in hip-hop
the all of that alienation being given
an articulated voice in an artistic
sense and that's a good example of the
power of verbal facility and that's the
route to let's say marketing education
to young men it's like you want to
you want to take your rightful place in
the kingdom it's like get your tongue
straight man get it under control
in the highest possible sense we went to
a comedy club tammy and i and
in uh new york the comedy cellar it's a
great comedy club and the last comic was
an english guy and uh
he was
not particularly physically
pre-possessing and he he made a lot of
jokes about that and it was quite funny
and then he divided the audience into
five sections and he asked each section
to toss up a topic just to yellow the
topic
and they were like random topics like
the kennedy assassination and
electric lighting before 1890 those were
two of the topics and the other three
were just as diverse
and then he put on some beats and he did
about an eight minute wrap
with every
verse
rhymed
and he tied the whole thing together at
the end and ended at the end of the
music all spontaneously
it was unbelievable
and that's logos man that's the
redemptive power of the logos right
there the magic word the sacred word
it's just manifesting itself on stage
this is very impressive something about
that that does feel dangerous as well
and not in a
i need to be concerned and this should
be contaminated and walled off but in a
way that you think
that person has so much competence
that it it's flowing out of them and you
almost feel competent by being around
them so you certainly feel competent by
appreciating it yeah right because it
speaks to the part of you that is
capable of appreciating such things you
think wow that's really something that's
really that's an amazing display that's
an amazing thing to see amazing right
a very interesting word amazing and
you're you're trapped and you're trapped
by the charisma of that and that
charisma that's not nothing that's
that's a signal of something redemptive
occurring that that accounts for
virtually all of the attraction of
hip-hop and rap
it's the articulate articulated voice of
the
struggling
but worthy
underclass i suppose that's a good way
of putting it but those who are
alienated
from their rightful place
and so that verbal prowess is one of the
ways they
struggle up towards the light you know
and and that that's a good example of
that uh
of having that danger under control
because it's a dark genre in many ways
right it's it's a
there's a there's a there's a real
undercurrent an era of violence that
surrounds
that and its culture like the punk
movement in the in in in the uk back in
the late 70s same same sort of thing
but that that capacity to express that
in a poetic manner
in a compelling manner sid or johnny
rotten was great at that he's so intense
his he worked with pil afterwards public
in public image limited as that is a
public image i think so he has a song
called rise which i used to show my
my clients all the time when i was
starting uh
assertiveness training with them i'd put
on
johnny rotten's
rise and the line in there is anger is
an energy and he's got these
unbelievably intense eyes anger is an
energy you bet and john lyden man he
could channel that like almost no one
i've ever seen he'd get that anger built
up inside him and then it was completely
under control and he expressed it in his
music and he's absolutely captivating
unbelievably charismatic and i really
liked his music that raw anger in the
music that but it was
it was in the bloody music wasn't it
it wasn't some random riot you know
he transmuted that into something you
know you can argue about the poetic
merits of um
of punk rock although i don't think you
should
i mean
i did it my way sid vicious version of i
did it my way my god that's a work of
genius that it's so it's so brilliantly
satirical
what someone's doing is they're refining
it they're distilling it down and then
they're directing it so i went to a
powerlifting competition a couple of
years ago there's this one guy there
lifting he holds a bunch of records in
the squat
and he's a normal working class guy from
a normal working-class town on the
outskirts of newcastle and watching that
man warm up
is
something else he's got a sacred
playlist he never listens to the songs
apart from when he's about to step on to
the lifting platform
he's got these headphones on and he's
just walking up and down in the same way
that you'd see a bull
ready ready to go out ready to go and
chase something and he steps out on
stage
and the hares stand up on the back of
your neck you're watching this guy
channel
ray fury that's the god of war that's
mars yeah he's in touch with that
unbelievable and words man you go to war
with words
and you think that's what young men
should be taught
there we go
bit of fury
um i want to talk about your recovery
can you explain
how it felt in the first few days when
you realized that it might be over when
the clouds were
lifting you know what happened very
incrementally
over a period of months
well things were slightly less
catastrophic in the morning it was
taking me
three and a half hours to stand up
and then it was only taking like
three hours
so that looked like maybe something had
improved
it was very slow like the question about
when did you get old yeah yeah exactly
one day at a time exactly so you know
and i still have a lot of
pain
i mostly
feel like i have a bad flu all the time
but that's way better than it was
so
what's changed on the other side of that
do you view
the way that you should be in the world
different do you feel like you have a
new purpose after being ill for so long
hopefully i'm more grateful for the mere
absence of catastrophe
you know and i'm i guess i'm
possibly more pleased to be out say
doing this lecture tour i mean i was
really pleased about it in 2018 i was
already pretty damn happy about
happy isn't the right word
um overwhelmed grateful
uh
in a state of constant disbelief
thrilled about the fact that people were
responding so positively amazed about
the fact that this had like a religious
dimension
um
[Music]
overjoyed to see people come and tell me
that they had got their lives together
and that they were very happy about that
i had all that already maybe i feel that
more
now
i i wouldn't say that
i've learned so much that all the pain
was worth it
but
that's that's i suppose in some sense
putting a happy ending on something in a
way that's just too trite it's like it
it was uh
most of that time i would have
far rather been dead for all sorts of
reasons
so now i'm perfectly happy that i'm not
but i haven't forgotten what that was
like
there's a lot of people that are very
glad that you're not
yeah well that's that that's great
really that's great you know and i'm
thrilled that i'm about
being able to be
uh
not terrifying to my family let's say
and
i'm really happy to be back out in
public and to be
to be doing what we're doing my you know
along with my daughter and my wife and
with the support of my family it's great
i love this tour
it's so nice to meet all these people
it's so positive it's ridiculously
positive
and in a world where so much is negative
and ridiculously negative
um that's that's a lovely thing to see
and to see these thou i'm gonna see 150
000 people in the united states you know
between
when the tour started which was about
two weeks ago and the end of
i think it's the end of april
before we go to canada and then to the
uk and then to europe and then to
australia new zealand and southeast asia
and russia
all of that's
on the table
and to see
150 000 people who are
committed enough to trying to make their
lives better to come to the lectures and
to listen to them even though they're
essentially
philosophical
treatises or at least the best i can
manage in
an hour
and to watch people be committed to this
and to hear their stories
it's
you can't imagine anything could be more
positive than that and so that's
wonderful if there's something to come
back to
after having that that's not much better
that you could have arrived back into a
world to find
no
no i mean the
the the downside of it is that
there's such a need for it
you know because part of what i think i
have to offer perhaps is encouragement
because i don't think the planet would
be better off with fewer people on it
and i don't think that the ambitious
motivations of young men are nothing but
the manifestation of the corrupt will to
power etc etc
and the fact that
so many people are
pining away
nihilistically in some sense
in no small part because of such
accusations because they're being taken
out by their own conscience
i think that's absolutely appalling and
seeing how positive people are in
relationship to
what i'm doing
has that as its shadow which is well
isn't it so awful that that's necessary
yeah so
but it is necessary by all appearances
at least to the people that seem to be
listening to me and
so c'est la vie and you know i do
believe and i think my family is firmly
behind me in this belief that
you know this
the idea that the planet has too many
people on it's sort of a group idea you
know
there's too many people is like the mass
of people
and
the mass is too big i don't think of
people as a mass
i think of people as individuals
and so there are not there's not a mass
of people it's the wrong level of
analysis as far as i'm concerned
the right level of analysis is
each person
and and i i think that that's a core
tenet of
the of western civilization to the
degree that the west is actually
civilized let's say the more it's
civilized the more the emphasis is on
the individual and
the idea that the individual is
sovereign is the core axiom of western
civilization democracy itself
and i believe that that statement is as
true as any statement we've managed to
collectively formulate
and so if it's true then it is
the real battle is at the level of the
individual or even within the individual
and
that's fine with me and so mostly what
i'm doing is attempting to make
connections with individuals even though
i'm talking to
thousands and thousands of people i'm
never talking to them as a group
ever i don't even look at them as a
group i never look at the crowd
when i'm talking to my audiences i
always look at one person you know it's
not always the same person because that
makes them uncomfortable they're happy
to be singled out for a second or two
but it gets weird if it's 10 minutes
so i'm always looking at you know one
person or another but i'm always talking
to one person
i learned that in part from kierkegaard
you know
because kierkegaard believed firmly that
as soon as the truth was embodied by the
mob it was no longer a truth the truth
was in and of itself something that was
always manifested at the level of the
individual people know this
they know this in their own lives that
you have wisdom on your own you go into
a group and you compromise that wisdom
for some reason social norms or the way
you've dealt with past traumas or the
the things that you think of the people
want to hear from you you know that's
diffusion of responsibility right
because when you're when you're buried
in the mob you can do and say things
that
that the mob
hides from you in the world whereas if
you're just operating on your own that
the consequences of your actions are
manifested pretty quickly no place to
hide so
we have to keep
you know every group of people isn't a
mob either i mean there are groups of
people that are decentralized highly
functioning
aggregates hierarchies composed of
individuals and
that's working at every level of
analysis and that's a properly
functioning society that's not a mob
at that point there's a dynamic
that permeates the entire hierarchy
that keeps the individuals let's say at
the bottom of the hierarchy
completely in touch with those
smaller that smaller number of people
who are at the top and a good how
well-functioning
democratic political state has that
nature is that there's constant
communication upward and downward
just like the way the brain is organized
the brain's a hierarchy but information
doesn't just propagate from the bottom
up or from the top down even with your
visual system so for example when
information first enters your brain from
your eyes
at the foveal level each foveal that's
the center part of your vision that's
high resolution every cell in your fovea
is represented by 10 000 cells at the
first level of visual processing
and so there's a tremendous amount of
input from your eyes to your brain
bottom up but even at the very bottom of
visual perception there's more top down
connections from your brain
so the visual system is hierarchical
but each level of the hierarchy
communicates all the way down the
hierarchy and a good political system is
structured that way and so you can have
a group of people that's not a mob
and it's a different way it's a
different organization and a democratic
a democratic polity is not a mob not if
it's functioning properly
you know it's something that was really
brought home to me when i went to
england because i went into the lobby of
the house of parliament this great domed
building that's more or less at the
center of the parliamentary cross
and that's where
citizens of of great britain can come
and lobby to to to speak to their
representative
so that's where the voice of the people
meets the voice of the representatives
and that's how it should work is
in some sense there are emotions and
concerns that are
stirring in an inarticulate manner
at the bottom of the of the hierarchy
where where the problems first manifest
themselves because they always first
manifest themselves at the bottom of a
hierarchy
those problems aren't necessarily easy
to articulate and so people stumble
forward with their concerns and the job
of their representatives is to take
those stumbling concerns and aggregate
them and to give them voice and to
transmit them up the structures of power
to transform the laws into the new body
of laws which is what we act out to to
reconcile the bottom with the top and
that has to just happen continually
because it's it's a living it's like a
living organism well it is in a sense it
is a living organism because it's a meta
organism that consists of living
organisms so you know for all intents
and purposes it's something that's alive
i really really hit me
in the lobby that's where the word
lobbying comes from by the way
so it happened there
and and people are cynical about
lobbying but
people are cynical about lots of things
and it's not that helpful
is it possible to have too much
responsibility to take too much
responsibility for yourself like
one thing i've been thinking is that
the victim mindset where you want to
you believe that you have no control
over the outcomes in your life
i wonder whether there's an opposite
where you believe that you have an
infinite amount of control over them and
you lose faith in your innate ability to
just carry you through
i've been thinking a lot about releasing
the tiller which is a jed mckenna quote
he's talking about the fact that the
best way to
ride a boat
through a storm is to actually release
the tiller and it allows the boat to
maneuver best through the swells and i
think that a lot of the time going back
to the imposter syndrome thing that we
were talking about as you start to
accumulate more and more competence
the
higher level of overthinking the higher
level of neuroticism the more of an
attention to detail that got you from
naught to 50 isn't necessarily the thing
that's going to get you from 50 to 100
you know you had to get across a river
and it was it was bad and difficult you
don't need to carry that boat across
ground to then get you across the next
one and i wonder whether
the opposite of a victim mentality where
you take responsibility for the things
that occur in life
i wonder whether you can overshoot you
can for sure yeah definitely
i mean
you know dostoevsky said that every man
was responsible for everything he did
and
for
and for everything that everyone else
does which is kind of an insane
statement but also
somewhat it's true in in in a certain
sense
you do have an indefinite responsibility
and you do have an indefinite capacity
to bear that responsibility but that
doesn't mean it can't be crushing and
then i would say the antidote to that is
that you're not in this alone
as your responsibilities mount
and your opportunities
increase
you have to delegate more and more
there's enough for every
there's a it's important that you do
everything you can but there's enough
for everyone to do
and so you might say well
the heroic path is one that leads to
universal redemption and that's true and
you might say well that's all on you
it's like it is in a sense but then
the problem that you just described
comes out children too much better well
it can crush you it can be unsustainable
right you can torture yourself for not
doing it well enough
and it is up to you but it's not up to
you alone
it's not up to you alone
so you delegate you and you you build
you help build people around you
so that they're all working in the same
direction it's an effort it's an effort
multiplier in any case and you make sure
that they get credit they and i they get
they get
credit isn't exact credit's good enough
it's it's not exactly right
the rewards
are are in accordance with their efforts
and you can distribute that you know
because there's also a narcissism that
can come along with that which is well
it's all up to me
and even if you're working in a very
competent manner it can seem that way
but
there's plenty of work to go around and
there's plenty of credit where credit is
due and so what you do as you attain
more responsibility and opportunity is
you delegate more of that and you do
that continually i mean one of the roles
of a good manager is to make him or
herself irrelevant absolutely yeah right
so if you're not a good manager if your
company would collapse if you
disappeared
that should all be delegated out and
it's not because you're abdicating
responsibility because also what happens
is that if you can recognize someone
something and parse it off to someone
else say here's a little kingdom for you
and it doesn't have to be little and
it's something that can grow but here's
a kingdom for you
well then you can go off and do the next
thing you need to do which is extremely
important you know and you might think
there's there's a kingdom and then it's
broken into little kingdoms and so the
farther you are down the hierarchy the
smaller the kingdom you get but that's
only true if you think the world's a
zero-sum game
because you could also think of it as a
place of indefinite
a place with an indefinite number of the
largest kingdoms possible
and i think what why do we think this is
exhaustible in some sense what we're
doing it doesn't look exhaustible you
know that's the limits to growth
mentality it's like
economists don't believe in that
because they think well no we can just
get more efficient which we certainly
are we're way more efficient than we
once were
and those gains in efficiency when
they're not being interfered with are
increasing at
more than an arithmetic rate why do you
think people
have a tendency toward that zero-sum
mentality
when i find myself thinking that it's
one of the first things that i check
myself on that is
that is cancer
yeah well i mean there are elements of
life that have a zero-sum element i mean
if you're competing with another man for
example to marry a particular woman
that's a zero-sum game if you only think
of the game as including you two and
that woman so you can set up
circumstances that are zero-sum
but then port them across into
situations which aren't yeah well then
but to take take that metaphor of zero
sum game where there has to be winners
and losers because there's a finite
number of resources is to assume that
the rules of that game are the rules
that govern all game the set of all
games and that's just not true there's
games are infinitely multipliable i mean
you can invent a new game people do that
all the time the man who invented catan
which is a game i really like to play
it's very popular board game that didn't
exist until he invented it now you know
thousands and thousands of people play
it and he made a fortune from it's like
that game never existed
so
there doesn't seem to be any limit to
the number of games we can invent
and
it's a complicated problem because we
are on a single planet and
and
some resources are more zero-sum than
others but
we haven't really run into any actual
zero-sum limits in terms of our
you know the probability of us living an
abundant life on the planet
we've we've stewarded some resources
very stupidly we've done a very bad job
of of managing
oceanic production for example
although
fish farms have alleviated that on the
production side to some degree but
it's a tragedy of the commons that we
could address and should address as far
as i'm concerned one of the good things
the trudeau government has done i think
to give the devil is due let's say is to
put a lot of the coast of
canada into marine protected areas and
that's smart we have to be smart about
our resources but that doesn't mean
there's zero sum and certainly doesn't
mean the world is a zero-sum game and
that's a malthusian idea you know that
population will grow till it consumes
all available resources and
precipitously collapse
and then why do we think apocalyptically
it's well because things do come to
sudden ends
people die people get fatal illnesses
like the world you so carefully
constructed can be blown apart at any
moment by a random occurrence genetic
mutation that causes the cancer that
kills you like life has a life has a
fundamentally apocalyptic aspect and we
do understand that because we're
self-conscious and then it's very
difficult not to apply that kind of
apocalyptic reasoning to
things as such
the world's going to burn up
the climate's too hot what about runaway
positive feedback loops because that's
what the climate types are afraid of
it's like hey they happen
how do we bind our apocalyptic thinking
that's a good question man
that's a good question we do that
through truth
we do that with the truth that's how we
do it through dialogue through
investigation through exploration
through discipline
all of that the logos is the antidote to
the apocalypse of course that's central
christian dogma isn't it that the logos
is the apoc is the antidote to the
apocalypse
[Music]
fancy that
and so what does that mean well love and
truth is the antidote to the apocalypse
not the planet has too many people on it
you
said to me when we went out for dinner a
couple of months ago
i asked you what i should be doing with
my life and you said what you're doing
right now
i think
is pretty good and then you said
truth in the service of love
what do you mean by that he's brought it
up again
well it's a hierarchy of virtue i would
say you know there's an old idea that
god is the sum
of all that's good
i don't think some is exactly the right
metaphor
it's more like imagine there are eternal
verities truth beauty justice love
courage
fortitude
compassion
think of all those things as virtues
so virtue is what all virtues have in
common virtue is what all virtues have
in common
that's the relationship of god to the
good
god is
the essence of the good
so
we put that aside for a moment
or you may think how would that manifest
itself
in your life well that might be pursuit
of the good and that's the pursuit of
the good that unites all proximal goods
and
well what is that exactly well it's
something like the
belief that it would be for the best
that all things flourish to the degree
that that's possible when when i was a
clinician i thought of that as the good
in
me serving the best in my clients
and i think the desire for that to
happen that's love
so that's the desire
for
you say well you take a human bent
broken miserable malevolent
hurt corrupt weak pathetic contemptible
frustrating disappointing
all of those things that we can lay on
ourselves because of our inadequacies
it's like
it's easy to dismiss that and part of
that dismissal is what drives the notion
that the planet has too many people on
it and that we're a cancer on the face
of the earth
it's like it's not easy to love that
but what do you want you want the broken
people to rise up
out of their brokenness
rather than despise them for it
and then you orient yourself towards
that and try to pull that out of people
and yourself and
and
that you have to have that frame
first that's what you're aiming for and
maybe
that would be the opposite of hell this
is one thing i would say that unites sam
harris and i despite our differences in
in belief in some sense at the level of
detail sam is very acutely aware of the
reality of malevolence and hell now he
wouldn't frame that metaphysically or
religiously but doesn't really matter
he is doing his best
to aim away from that as hard as he
possibly can i didn't realize the last
time i talked to him that sam identified
the religious
tradition the dogmatic religious
tradition with the totalitarianism that
produces atrocity now i think that's a
misidentification
the same way the marxists blame
inequality on capitalism inequality is
really a problem
but it's not the fault of capitalism and
totalitarian atrocity is really a
problem but to identify that reflexively
with religion
or even with religious dogma that's a
mistake dogma maybe but even that's
tricky because what's the difference
between dogma and knowledge you know
today's knowledge is tomorrow's dogma
and drawing the line between those two
is extremely difficult you can't just
abandon everything you think even though
it's arbitrary
you need it to guide you
and it can transform into totalitarian
dogma and
promote atrocity in the servants of in
the service of it's no longer valid
maintenance
but
that's a very complicated problem
so if that's love love yeah truth
truth in the service of love
[Music]
well truth to begin with is
well okay we could take that apart a bit
what you talked about letting the tiller
of the boat go
well
imagine that you treat
so we're having this conversation let's
say i want this conversation to go
the best way it can possibly go
okay well i don't know what that way is
but i have to want that to begin with
so i come to the conversation i think
i'm going to try to have the most
engaging
conversation that i can have i'm going
to say what i believe to be the case
during the conversation there isn't
something i want from you except that
hopefully we can meet in that endeavor
i'm not trying to craft outcome i don't
know what we're going to talk about you
know we talked a little bit about
possible broad themes although i don't
think we touched on any of the things we
actually discussed
that doesn't mean we didn't need to do
the preparation
no
and then you think well
whatever we accomplish in the course of
a genuine dialogue is for the best and
that's to let go of the of the tiller
and truth does that it's like because
you can't craft the outcome
and so what you're doing
by engaging in truthful dialogue is
letting the wind blow where it's going
to blow and you do that if you've
decided at some fundamental level even
if you don't know you've decided that
that the truth will set you free and the
truth is what is
in the final analysis redemptive
and we tend to think of truth
we tend to think that truth resides in a
set of accurate facts
that's actually the weakness i would say
of the materialistic atheist
position
that axiomatic
presumption about the nature of the
truth but the truth is a process
it's it's it's and it's often a
dialogical process
so the truth is the thing that emerges
in the course of the search for the
truth it's something like that
and true truth is to be found in the
search for the truth
that's the process that continually
revitalizes things
and so
and then if your orientation is towards
the good
to the degree that your orientation is
towards the good and your belief that
the good can prevail
which is which is
an article of faith right the good can
prevail it's like what's your evidence
for that
there's evidence for whatever position
you want to hold on that so it's a
decision
and you let go and the truth takes you
away and you think that it's going to go
where it should go
you put you commit yourself to that idea
and then that's your adventure that's
the thing that's one of the things
that's so cool about that it's like you
need this adventure to buttress you
against tragedy there's nothing more
adventurous than the truth
and in fact it's the only true adventure
obviously
you just have to think that through
for
20 minutes
how could it be a true adventure if it
wasn't true
and then why is an adventure if it's
true because you're not crafting the
outcome
and so what does that mean it means
you've decided that the truth is what
will set you free and and that's
independent in some sense of the
evidence one of the things my family has
learned this has taken a lot of learning
is that
there's been at least i would say 50
times in the last five years
where we thought we'd be taken out by
what was happening around us sometimes
those were big things there was probably
10 of them like they were public and
famous
and then there was like 40
things that weren't so big but were
still plenty big it was always the same
thing it was
hot as hell for
weeks
but
flipped
always
always but that doesn't mean it was
pleasant to live through the part when
it wasn't flipping
it was horrible
but so far
so far
we've been able to let go of the tiller
and
let the waves take us where they'll take
us and not flip the boat
do you think that there's a usefulness
in having a nemesis to motivate you
talking about some of the situations
that you've been through not
particularly those ones exactly but
i try to avoid making enemies of people
or groups or ideas or whatever yes don't
make unnecessary enemies but
there is an extra level of fire that
gets lit underneath you when you're
going up against someone and i miss it
sometimes there's a price that you pay
for peace
yeah well then you just have to look at
yourself harder and find the nemesis
because it's there all the time
right i mean there's always parts of
yourself that you can overcome
and so that's william james moral
equivalent to war essentially now if you
need something to grapple with and
you probably do
you can find that you just look inside
you'll find something to grapple with
you know inadequacy weakness
susceptibility to temptation narcissism
pride
envy revenge resentment frustration lack
of faith all of that
that that'll keep you occupied if you
really grapple with it and yeah i mean
that's an ancient theological question
you know what's up with the devil
why why is that why does the possibility
of evil exist why is there an eternal
adversary you see that reflected in cain
and abel right at the beginning of the
genesis stories essentially the first
two human beings are
good set against an adversary and that's
that's what opens history that story you
think well why would god construct such
a
why would god construct a reality where
an adversary exists and maybe it's
because all things considered a world
with an adversary is a better world just
like a garden with a snake and it is a
better garden
these things aren't easy to understand
no no snake no necessity to contend with
snakes
so why be awake
at all
no adversary no challenge why be
challenged because maybe you're better
for the challenge
and maybe that's the challenge to see if
you can be better for the challenge but
that should be internal well
fundamentally well if it isn't you'll
find it externally because you'll
demonize someone to turn them into satan
so that you can find an adversary and
then that's very unfortunate for you and
for them
that's just not as big a battle it's
like you you battle with someone
external who's malevolent let's say or
you think they are and usually you've
got that mostly wrong but not always
but if the battle is inside which is
where it's supposed to be
most fundamentally then
well then it's the ultimate it is the
ultimate challenge and that's the
infinite game
the external battle between good and
evil on a playing field of chaos and
order that's the eternal game
and you know you can play that out in
the external world but
part of what
the religious enterprise
is about
and the christians have really
contributed to this
is the notion that that sacred battle is
fundamentally spiritual
which is to say in some sense
fundamentally psychological it's to be
it's to be fought on the battleground of
the soul
internally it's a subjective issue how
do you defeat evil
you defeat the evil in your own heart
that's that is how you do it
and so if that's all being acted out
for you in the world well you you've
misplaced satan that's a good way of
thinking about it this is another
weakness i think of the atheistic
position because
you can it's pretty hard it's an easy in
some sense to dispense with belief in
the highest good but it's not so easy to
dispense with belief and evil
so that's a big problem so then where do
you localize it
and you can find evidence of it
everywhere certainly in institutions i
mean that's the whole systemic racism
corrupt patriarchy narrative is that
satan is to be found at the core of our
institutions and to some degree that's
true
because everything we do is corrupt to
some degree
and so then do you fight it
sociologically you're the good person
and
the the institution is
satan
so you're so good are you
you're so sure of that are you
you've got everything in order or do you
and you might say well do you have to
have everything in order before you
fight evil on the sociological front and
the answer is well no because you're
never going to have everything in order
but
you still shouldn't put the cart before
the horse
it's really it's a spiritual battle and
it's taken people thousands and
thousands of years to figure this out
now first of all it was the snake
what's what's evil what's malevolent the
predatory reptile
fair enough man i mean we've been
fighting with predatory reptiles for 60
million years as mammals 60 million
years
so it's a good first pass approximation
it's the snake the poisonous snake the
external enemy the predator
but what about the predator and other
people
oh yeah that's even worse man it's like
how predict predators are one thing but
predatory people other tribes men
they're brutal they're brutal
well what about your predatory friend
oh that's pretty bad too the friend who
stabs you in the back the person who
betrays you judas god maybe that's the
ultimate snake it's like well how about
when you betray yourself
oh yeah
so you want to see there's this
association that's very strange that
occurred in the development of christian
thought between the snake in the garden
of eden and satan there's no indication
in the original story that the snake has
anything to do with the lord of all evil
it's a very weird
conclusion that's been drawn it's almost
extra biblical because there's almost no
mention of satan in the bible at all
much less any direct connection between
the serpent and satan it's a very very
strange idea but it's part of this
psychologization of evil it's like
what's the ultimate predator
what's the ultimate predator
what's the enemy you harbor in your own
heart who hates you
that's the ultimate predator
oh and when there's these images of mary
uh
with her head in the stars and baby in
her arms and her foot on a snake it's
like well
that's the eternal feminine head's in
the stars because she's oriented towards
the highest good and she's protecting
her infant from predators
that could be
an actual predator but that has been the
case throughout not just human history
but mammalian history
could be
other people who are
predators it could be men who are
predators
could be her
who's a predator
a devouring mother
it's like well
what's what's the ultimate locale of
genuine evil well the
highest religious answer is
that's in you
that's the proper place to battle it out
and
i think that's true
i think that's lit it's literally and
metaphorically true and i i was
convinced of that in part because of
social instance writings because
solzhenitsyn identified the totalitarian
state with the
willingness of
the subjects of that state the subjects
and the perpetrators at the same time
to live by lies
no to no law no totalitarian state if
people don't lie
every time you lie in support of the
totalitarian state then you're the
perpetrator and that's a psychological
issue it's like you're going to lie to
get along or not
say well what does it matter
i'll go along with it it's okay
we'll see how it matters
because it matters
and that's all psychodrama as far as i'm
concerned
but fundamentally when it's properly
placed
you've got plenty of problems to take
care of on your own front
and that's where you should concentrate
your efforts
one of the things that i've realized is
that
people that are self-reflective
that rely on cerebral horsepower
that pay attention that think in a
detailed way
the more nuance that you're thinking is
the fewer people are going to be like
you
which
makes you feel more alone
how do you think people can overcome
this
well i would say that hasn't been my
experience exactly
because
as i started to make my thoughts more
public
they seem to appeal to more and more
people
and so i don't know if that's a
threshold phenomena because maybe it is
you know
as you start to become specialized as a
scientist
in some sense your vision narrows and
narrows
although it gets more high resolution at
the level that you're operating but you
kind of pass through a
needle let's say
out the other side where the thing
you're studying starts to become
everything again
and so maybe that's maybe that's that
developmental progression further more
yeah specialization and then
generalization again yeah yeah i think
that you might be right there the deeper
into the breach thing the show that i
went to go and see you do in manchester
in 2017 or 18
someone asked a question about um the
depth of my consciousness causes me to
suffer and you said you take more of the
thing that poisons you until you turn it
into a tonic that girdles the world
around you and i think that this is
something you see here as well that when
you start to think differently when you
start to consider the way that you're
living your life in a
more detailed higher resolution
more unique more nuanced way
you will probably receive pushback
especially you know speaking from
personal experience in a normal
working-class towns people born live die
in these places
it's insular
there isn't a huge
culture of especially in the uk tall
poppy syndrome is a huge problem the
biggest difference that i've noticed
actually between
american people and english people
is that american children are told that
they can be anything that they want to
be
they're told that they have blue sky
vision they can achieve whatever they
want and that gives them a lot of
confidence
when us brits stuffy stiffer brits see
americans on tv it sounds like
everyone's had media training because
everybody's just so enthused about
whatever it is even if it's a 18-car
pileup
and then the
equivalent in the uk is that
deviating from the norm is very very
very
quickly mocked
and there's a lot of that in canada too
tall puppy syndrome it's a big deal
now
the japanese have that saying too except
it's um
the nail that sticks up above all the
rest is the first one to be struck down
by the hammer
and there's some truth in that too
there's some truth in that but
some
and all are very different words
when you roll the clock forward what you
end up with
is american children that then become
adults
who
look around at the world and say well
hang on this wasn't what i was promised
i was told that i could be anything that
i wanted to be i was told that i could
have anything that i wanted to there's a
difference between you can earn
everything that is earnable and you
deserve everything there is
so that message can become
what you say it can become
misinterpreted in a narcissistic manner
and i think that has happened to some
degree especially as people have had
fewer and fewer children
you know
jonathan height and luke enough talk
about the coddling of the american mind
and they think about that in large part
as a consequence of
an ideological transformation
and some of that's true but it's also
useful to look at more fundamental
phenomena
people have children when they're a lot
older
they have way fewer children they have
way more resources when they have
children on average you know if you're
one kid of eight you're pretty much
battling it out for attention for a very
finite amount of parental attention with
a lot of intense competition
and the probability that you're going to
come out of that entitled and
narcissistic is pretty damn low because
your siblings will definitely punish you
for that but if you're the only child
especially of older parents who are also
more conservative because of their age
and also less willing to take chances
with you because there's only one of you
and then you have a lot of resources at
your disposal well that's a whole
different that's a whole different
developmental milieu and we have no idea
what the consequences of that are but
the idea that children in that
circumstance are more likely to be
overprotected and dependent and
structured it's like well yeah
undoubtedly
and you know that that would even be an
overabundance of parental virtue in some
sense right
well we just did nothing but pay
attention to our child
okay but
too much what did you expect
it's so strange because i'm an only
child right and
all of the well maybe my friends might
say differently
but a lot of the commonly held
presumptions around only children
i just and i have a couple of friends
who are as well and i don't know whether
it's where we're from that the northeast
of the uk is very spit and sawdust it's
salt of the earth people it's you know
grab your boots straps on your boots and
start pulling and
i just haven't i haven't seen that what
what is it
through your clinical practice would
not be a
primarily working class phenomena you
know that the coddled mind phenomena
that could easily be a middle class an
upper phenomena is there something is
was there a common trend or from your
reading have you found that only
children
tend to be one way or another no
no i just get huge variants in them as
well i don't know the answer to that at
the level of individual psychological
data there might be a literature i'm not
aware of it that for me that was more
response to heights book on the caudal
mind i thought okay
fair enough coddling of the american
mind what's driving this
it's not just ideas it's a huge
demographic switch it's a huge
transformation in the way we raise
children we're 10 years older when we
have our children now that's a lot older
you know when you're 18 you have a kid
you're still a kid and that there's some
wildness that's perhaps not so good
about that but there's also perhaps
a higher proclivity to go off and live
your own life
and then you know the how how much
children how much should your children
be left on their own
the answer is as much as they can
tolerate
and how much is that well
you find out with each child but it's
certainly possible to
not deprive your child enough
so
i've realized that
it's scary when you find a thing that
you're going to fully commit yourself to
the pursuit of especially if it's
excellence that you're going after
because there's no more room for your
inadequacies to hide
anymore you can't decide to change
direction and do something else if
things get tough there's no more
rejecter seat right i've committed to
this this is my thing and this is one of
your rules you know commit to something
is committed to at least one thing as
hard as you can yeah and see what
happens yeah precisely aim yourself in
one direction and
i had a rule with my clients because you
know you might say well i've gone
halfway down this path and i found out
it's wrong so how do you distinguish
that from just giving up well that's a
really hard question right it's it's a
moral hazard
because it's inappropriate to continue
in a direction you now realize to be
wrong but it's also inappropriate to
give up and
use that rationalization as an excuse
and how do you distinguish especially
seeing as we're not transparent to
ourselves well right exactly so that is
genuinely a moral hazard so one of the
principles that i tried to abide by in
my therapeutic discussions was you can
change course as long as the next thing
you do is equally or more difficult
because that's a check against just
giving up
so
you want to discipline yourself so you
can get yourself organized so that you
can go in a particular direction so that
when you find the right direction you
can really go in that direction and that
does require an apprenticeship of sorts
and it it might not matter in some sense
exactly what the apprenticeship is
as long as it is
rigorous
right and so
that's sort of a bridge between moral
relativism and moral absolutism
there's lots of games you can play
it's not that obvious a priori which is
the best game so that's kind of a
morally relative stance there's multiple
playable
games
but then the absolute is yeah but you
have to play one of them you have to
learn to play one of them you have to
become an expert at at least one of them
and then that's not a relative
proposition
and i i believe that's true
that seems to me to be the case so you
want to commit to something
and then you you have when you commit to
something you
require yourself to bring all of your
disparate disparate components
moving in a single direction united in a
single direction so it's a unifying it's
a unifying act
and then once having been unified
well then you can bring that unity to
bear on a variety of different tasks but
you have to bring it together first
so and that that makes sense
developmentally you see children
start out
as a disparate bundle of motivations and
emotions sort of warring with one
another
and then they can integrate that into
single games that they can play with
themselves
and then they integrate that with games
they start to play with other people and
all of that is integration
it's not subjugation it's not repression
not if it's a good game it's integration
you want to get integrated because then
you have
all the horses that are pulling your
chariot pulling in the same direction
and you're much more likely to get to
where you want to go then and also much
more likely to specify a good place to
go
so
that's another re that's something else
conservatives have to teach young people
which is well get yourself disciplined
well why
well not so you're a slave but so that
you could be a master
to use a terminology that you're not
supposed to use anymore but you know
this is in relationship to yourself
not to others
so
yeah and to begin with you have to
accept an external master
because
you just don't have the wisdom to do
that for yourself or the ability or the
opportunity often
everybody knows this
you know they feel bad when they
they decide they're going to put get
themselves in good shape and go to the
gym and lasts like three
temps yeah
and then
no one's happy about the fact that they
quit
and they berate themselves for it and we
know that we need to go through a
disciplinary process we need to
subjugate ourselves to a disciplinary
process that's part of the problem with
the constant harping about the you know
oppressive patriarchy
it's like you need a disciplinary
process
so
well that's just oppression and slavery
it's like no it's not
no more than a game is
not a good game good game isn't
oppression and slavery we saw
was it being on time being punctual was
laid at the feet of some oppressive
super supremacy yeah obviously
yeah that's utterly
imbecilic
i mean even at a scientific level
there's no that's trait
conscientiousness by the way to be
punctual part of orderliness and
dutifulness
industriousness there's no evidence
whatsoever that that varies by ethnicity
or race
or supremacy yeah or supremacy and it
there is evidence that if you are like
that you are more like supreme well you
are more likely to succeed it's one it
is the most determinating
it's the most
it's the most potent personality
predictor of
success in algorithmic domains
managerial administrative domains
so hard work works
and in fact the degree to which hard
work works is actually that one metric
of the
health of a society
the higher the correlation between
conscientiousness and outcome the
healthier the society well obviously why
well
you want the bulk of the credit to go to
the people who are the most productive i
mean
not because not even in some sense
because they deserve it
because what does deserve mean exactly
it is because they deserve it but
that's a black box that word it's
because
if you want them to keep making stuff
you have to do that
and you want them to because well or
what you don't want food
you don't want shelter
why would you not reward the people who
provide it differentially
just your own even your own narrow
self-interest would
require that
so
talking about committing to one thing
and the inevitable pain of
there not being an easy get out anymore
i've decided that this is my thing i'm
going after it yeah it's just useful to
stick a temporal parameter or an
accomplishment parameter on it that's
one of the reasons
for
yeah
yeah well
i'm gonna get this degree no matter what
well it's a time limit it's not your
whole life but you're committed to that
and then you do box yourself in it's
like well i'm in this box i have to make
the best of it that's right
you're in this box and you have to make
the best of it and you might say well i
don't want to be in a box like are you
so sure you don't want to be in a box a
box is a fortress the walls keep the
dragons away you want to be in a box
paradise is a walled garden
it's not a garden without walls it's got
walls right you have a house it has
walls you have a room it has walls
you don't want to be outside of a box
pick your damn box and then figure out
how to make it into a garden
well i want a box without walls no you
don't
it's nothing but snakes
yeah
you spoke about this last night in
relation to relationships and you said
that when you commit to somebody there
is the uh
inevitable pain
that any future catastrophe is going to
need to be worked out in a difficult way
between you and the person that you've
committed to as opposed to you being
able to go oh well cool i'm out of here
the side chicks are warm on tinder in
any case i'm off yeah right right right
well that was something i really learned
from reading carl jung he thought about
marriage as
he used alchemical symbolism as
requires heat
heat and pressure
and so you have a container and it gets
hot
and that's when you want to leave that's
when the changes can take place
and sometimes they have to be radical to
maintain the relationship
very radical but hopefully those radical
changes are positive but what makes you
think you'd make them if there wasn't a
fire lit under you and one of the fires
is i can't escape from you
here we are locked in combat right here
we are in this adversarial relationship
beneficial
exactly beneficial adversary yeah
there's no out except through
and there's no evidence that through
will work
but and so that's part of the utility of
the vow is to turn the temperature up
and you know you could say well i'll
escape but the problem with that is
escape to where
you're not going to have another
relationship and if to the degree that
you brought the catastrophe to the
previous relationship which is at least
a 50-50 probability right
what makes you think you're not going to
bring it to the next relationship you're
the common denominator between all of
the experts right i've had i've had many
bad relationships like really
i've never met anyone i can trust
okay
everyone's motivated by power
what's the common denominator here
exactly
so
you know it's tricky because i've
i mean lots of people in my family have
been divorced which is the case in
virtually every family and i don't feel
like i'm in a position to shake my
finger at people and say
you know you failed
and with more effort you could have
succeeded
that's not up to me to decide
and many of those people have gone on to
have more successful relationships
the second time around
but
that doesn't belie the initial point and
besides even the people who
went through a divorce wanted to get
married again they still see utility in
the vow and the container
so you know
you can't make these things into
inviolable absolutes
zero divorce zero drugs zero climate
change
no
that's that isn't how the world works
partly because there's always the snake
in the garden right there's no zero
not without the application of
increasingly totalitarian force
it has to be some leeway but you don't
blow the whole systems apart just to
provide some leeway it's a very
difficult thing to negotiate
you know i've had clients who had
partners that
really couldn't be negotiated with
the whole idea of negotiation wasn't
negotiable
and i didn't see they really had any
choice to either
maintain the millstone around their neck
and drown
or to leave
it's an awful choice but that doesn't
mean that marriage is a prison that no
one should ever enter
it just means that things are
complicated optimizing for absolutes
always ends up in
carl newport says this about email
really interesting insight he says that
one of the problems that you have with
anything is when you drive the cost down
to
literally zero you end up with a ton of
very weird externalities that you didn't
think of right and he made some argument
that every email should cost five pence
right right if every email cost five
pence you would receive ninety percent
fewer right right right yeah yeah the
proper it's very
we've wrestled with that very frequently
building these um
programs to help people
so with my colleagues both who are
psychologists one a clinical
psychologist one a research psychologist
we built personality tests to help
people understand their personalities
which also produces a couple's report so
that you can understand the differences
between you and your partner at a
temperamental level and we produce this
suite of writing programs that help
people write an autobiography and an
analysis of their virtues and faults and
a plan for the future and
you know one question is well why not
give it away
and the answer is because zero is not
the right cost
now what the right cost is that's really
tricky well that's why you have markets
is to determine what the right cost is
zero
it's like we've sold way more of these
than we would have ever given away
partly because people presume
that if it costs nothing it's worth
nothing
and partly because it isn't free
like we actually worked
well one of my partners were
pretty much full-time for 15 years on
this
at
sub-par wages making a tenth of perhaps
of what he could have made in the
private domain like if he would have
gone out and marketed his skills because
he's a brilliant programmer he has a phd
in psychology extraordinarily educated
unbelievably accomplished he could have
made a
fortune
in the private in other private
endeavors he worked at subpar wages for
15 years before we had any success on
this front at all
so it wasn't free
by any stretch of the imagination it was
unbelievably expensive for us to do this
and so then to
and then to say pillary
because somebody might say well if you
were really interested in the welfare of
the human race you wouldn't be making
money off your redemptive endeavors it's
like
what do you know about it
exactly have you ever tried to build
something and market it do you have any
idea what that entails
like first of all have you built
something that works that's scalable
that would help
you've demonstrated that it worked
you've done all that
and that's like you're five percent of
the way there buddy because you think
now you've got a good thing that people
will line up to use it
95 percent of the problem is marketing
and communication have you ever tried to
communicate about a product that you've
built
no
and you're telling me that somehow i'm
malevolent because i'm trying to make
enough money off this to
justify its existence to make sure that
i've designed it in a way that people
actually want you can tell that because
they'll pay for it in a way that will
sustain it and allow it to grow while
simultaneously trying to reward the
people that developed it that's all
wrong is it
and you know that
so no i'm i'm
i have a set of empty headed axioms
about inequality and i'm judging you
morally because of their what
injudicious application because that's
easier than thinking
that's where that argument goes it's
just irrational p price is an indicator
of quality and it's a commitment device
it's a rough indicator but it's better
than any other indicator we have yeah
you know generally if you want to buy a
suit a more expensive suit is better
but not always people hack this right
this is yeah that's right in the online
space they decide to ratchet up the
price of something that should have been
1 10th or 1 100. i thought this about um
james clear's atomic habits it was the
best-selling non-fiction book in the
world last year 2021 and it's great
and he sold this book for whatever
eight pounds on kindle and
12 pounds for a paperback if he decided
to release an online course of atomic
habits
60 days to a new you or something it
would have been
500 pounds or a thousand right right you
know so there's this odd tension now
that's happening between
people who have the capacity to improve
other people's lives where i know a lot
of authors who are coming into the
writing space from the online course
space
that they're thinking right okay well
i've i've made the money yeah now
because there is so much
disproportionate
um
fee that people are prepared to pay for
an online course the reason i think this
is the case is because people
are looking for outcomes with a lot of
personal development books and they feel
that they are closer to the outcome by
doing a course because it's going to be
more applied
well it's also the case that hardly
anyone reads
and listening and watching is way more
accessible to people way more like 10
times more
and this is actually going to start it
is already affecting the the author
market i would say i mean i talked to
sam harris about this a while back but
whether he was writing something and he
told me i hope i get this right and
certainly not a criticism of sam in any
case um
that the opportunity cost is too high
i mean look with a video the video we're
making right now is probably going to be
watched by a million people if i wanted
to write another book that reached a
million people it would take me two
years of writing and then a year of
marketing and the probability that will
happen even though i'm already a
successful author is still extremely low
whereas we can do this in two hours and
reach a million people was it some
studies perpetually uh perpetually
finding more urgent things to do right
something like that right right right
and and i mean the degree and the
repetitive communication online is
insane think about your
uh who was the guy that you did that
watched you do the
lecture series on in nashville he was
the psja psja yeah right how long did
that take two two half days
plus three or something like that three
half days plus a week of prep or
something like that right
right power loss man yes absolutely well
and and and then there's no lag to
publication
right and and that's an ever-growing
platform and it's accessible to 10 times
as many people and it's just as
permanent as a book now you might say
why ever write a book that's actually a
real question it's a question i've asked
myself because
some of the themes that i'm exploring in
my next book i've already talked about
in youtube videos let's say and they've
had quite an explosive
reaction to some of the ideas i talked
about the nature of the crucifixion
and uh
and the snake the relationship between
the image of the crucifixion and the
image of the snake i talked about that
on rogan and that was like two weeks ago
and i think probably 500 000 people have
seen that clip like that's more than a
best-selling book
instantly so why am i writing the book
and the answer is there's nothing that
requires you to think more deeply than
to write a book and so there's still an
intellectual advantage to that and a lot
of the things that i'm able to say so
quickly let's say like i did on rogan
you know it took 30 years to think
because you wrote those
exactly well i find this my newsletter i
do it once a week and
it it synthesizes whatever i've learned
over the last seven days right it takes
me you know a couple of hours to write
or whatever and it's less than a
thousand words you can read it in three
minutes three minute monday
[Music]
and so much of the stuff that i value
now that i talk about with friends or on
podcasts is something that imposter
adaptation you know that was something
i've been thinking about i wonder if i
can write this right in 500 words i
wonder if i can get it down in casual
language but does it concretizes what
you do this is why i say people that
don't have an outlet where
definitely if they don't have
conversations but also potentially if
they don't have the opportunity to write
about what they do about what they think
is that you just your thoughts are just
notions they're just this it's like a
low resolution ephemeral very difficult
to grasp wishy-washy thing
put it into words outside of your brain
put it into words say it to someone or
write it to someone see what happens
then it concretizes things well it also
edits it because so when you're writing
part of it is revelatory you write down
what you think but
you select what you think from the
multitude of revelations you don't write
down everything you think because you
can't so you have to select right away
and that's editing and then when you
actually technically edit what you've
written the same thing happens you
shrink it you you organize it you make
it coherent you get rid of what's
irrelevant and so that's tightens up
your thinking and then if you're
speaking with someone about what you're
thinking it's the same thing because
they'll object or they'll reward some of
it and so that's all that dialogue is
some of it's the generation of new ideas
but a tremendous amount of it is editing
what what's already you've already
revealed to yourself in this very vague
sort of dreamlike way
so
anything you want to say before we
finish up
i'd like to thank everybody who's
watching and listening and to thank you
and your crew for making this possible i
mean you guys you know you've put a lot
of effort into this come over from the
uk with your crew and you set this up
professionally and uh
and
it's a straightforward interview with no
tricks and
so that's not an easy thing to manage
and i appreciate the opportunity and
that's about that
jordan peterson ladies and gentlemen
thank you good to see you chris what's
happening people thank you very much for
tuning in if you enjoyed that episode
then press here for a selection of the
best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe peace